معدلات فائدة أعلى ، أكبر
زيادة في الأسعار منذ
عقود ، ستجعل اقتراض الأموال للعائلات والشركات أكثر تكلفة
بعد سنوات من الأموال الرخيصة ،
أصبحت ديونك أكثر تكلفة الآن ، وأصبحت المعدلات
الأعلى للرهون العقارية ، بطاقات الائتمان ، قروض السيارات
، ستكلف ديون الطلاب وقروض الأعمال
المزيد من التأثير الدراماتيكي بالفعل في
الرهون العقارية ، قفز الرهن العقاري ذو معدل الفائدة الثابت لمدة 30 عامًا
فوق 5 في المائة
الأسبوع الماضي من أقل من 3 بقليل
في معدلات نوفمبر الحضيض حتى الآن ، مما
أدى إلى تأجيج سوق الإسكان الحارقة ،
ونأمل أن تهدأ المعدلات المرتفعة ذلك ، فهناك
مدخرات أخرى مشرقة.  حسابات
لسنوات ، حيث يكافئ الاقتصاد على اقتراض
الأموال ، دون توفيرها ، ستبدأ حسابات التوفير
في الكسب مرة أخرى ، لكن قد
يستغرق الأمر وقتًا تكون البنوك أبطأ في تمرير
زيادات الفائدة إلى المدخرين
مقارنةً بفرض معدلات أعلى على
المقترضين ، وهذا تحول كبير
بالنسبة للمستهلكين  الذين سيحتاجون إلى سداد
الديون لتجنب ارتفاع التكاليف لتحملها